[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In these
courses, we deconstructed
the API product, introduced
the API product mindset,
reviewed the customer experience
with customer journeys
and personas, and
now, we would like
to offer a few tips on how
to formulate your API product
strategy, starting with the
design of your API products.
Recall the keys to an
API product mindset.
Approach the design with
the consumer in mind,
enable fast time to market
with reusable assets,
and don't boil the ocean.
But rather, iterate to
continuously improve
the product.
API products are your
digital product line.
And like any product line, it
can target different consumers
by adding small
tweaks to the product.
You should treat each API as
you would any other product you
produce in your organization.
One of the simplest
examples of a product
is made by the Coca-Cola
beverage company.
The company originally came
out with the Coca-Cola soda
and over the past 90
years have branched out
into fitness beverages,
teas, juices,
and different types of water.
Each product has its
own target audience.
For example, Adwala, Simply
Orange, and Minute Maid
are beverages targeted at
families with young children.
Fair Life and Core Power
are targeted at the health
conscious and fitness fanatics.
And the Coca-Cola company
also offers a variety
of water beverages, including
Smart Water, Vitamin Water,
and ZICO coconut water.
Similarly, your API
product strategy
will have different product
offerings for different target
audiences.
You may have an API product
for general partners
and a different API product
for closely held partners.
For example, those
partners that are
represented with the
business associates agreement
with our company.
Your product strategy will begin
to shape itself organically
as your product line grows and
is important that you focus
on your API consumer needs.
Consider any digital
transaction you engage in today.
Using your phone to buy coffee,
ordering something online,
and then tracking
the delivery, or even
updates in your bank account.
Each one of these
transactions is an experience
with an API behind it.
When you design API products,
you should ask questions like,
what problems do my
API consumers face?
How do I make the API
product easy to consume?
How might you measure the
impact of the solution
you provided them?
Taking a broader view,
you might ask yourself,
how do I get started?
And then a host of
follow-on questions arise,
like do I start
designing API products
for an internal
audience or jump right
into an external audience?
Can proxies be reused in
multiple API products?
Are there policies
that are standard
across the enterprise that
can be reused in API products?
The answers to these questions
will form your API product
strategy, and
furthermore, the strategy
must support your business.
With that said, as you embark
on your API product strategy,
the best way to help
guide your design
is to provide you
with an example.
Let's look at the leading ticket
sales and distribution company.
Their original target
audience for APIs
were their own
internal developers.
The company designed the
APIs around event discovery
and online ticket sales
to enable their developers
to bring new features to market
faster, and in the process
quickly found other
benefits when they
focused on the API consumer.
APIs were initially focused on
their internal developers who
were creating applications
for their internal call center
and online website for
purchasing tickets.
The focus was purely on the
needs of the internal developer
without much
reusability in mind.
The top two problems
the company faced
was how to secure the
connection and the data
for the application
and how to prevent bots
from simulating online
purchasers holding tickets
and thus driving up
the cost of the ticket
due to artificial demand.
In solving for the
problems, the company
found that the
security policies could
be reused by both internal
and partner developers,
and so they were able to
create API products were using
the same security policies for
partners, such as Costco, who
included the ability to search
for events and purchase tickets
on their website.
The company found that they
could create API products
for each trusted partner while
reusing the same security
policies and demand for their
API products amongst partners
grew.
Due to the high
demand, the company
found that they could engage
additional third party
supply to help meet the demand.
Demand continued to grow
with IoT devices coming
into the picture.
Consumers wanted to
search for events
in order tickets
via voice activated
devices, such as the
Google Home Assistant,
and thus, an API
product ecosystem
was born with demand and supply
running through the API product
ecosystem powered by the
Google Apigee platform.
The company grew from a
limited supply delivered
through a closed private
channel to a vibrant marketplace
with an ecosystem
of API products
with third party suppliers to
be consumed by new marketing
channels creating services
that the company didn't
need to build.
The added benefit was that
the new services cost little
to the company to provide.
There is no one approach to
designing your API product
strategy.
Rather, there is an
approach that you
can take to define an
initial API product design
and refine it over time.
Your API product strategy
will mature organically.
It's important that you
don't boil the ocean
to begin your journey.
Use customer
journeys and personas
to design API products that
have a notable business impact
and iterate from there.
Along your journey, you'll
find repeatable patterns,
such as the security
rules mandated
by your corporate
security office
that you will want to build
out as standard policies
for re-use.
It's always a good idea
to design your product
for external consumers, even
if your initial audience is
internal.
Finally, review actual
usage of your API products
and refine them based on your
metrics and user feedback
to continuously
improve your product.
Like your API products,
your product strategy
will evolve over time.
Hopefully, you found a few
strategies in this video
to define your API
product strategy.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]